il ya quelques semaines j'ai profité de
mes vacances à hawaï pour vous poser mon
énigmes préféré à savoir l'énigme des
deux enfants vous avez été très nombreux
à proposer vos solutions et je vous en
remercie
je trouve ça absolument génial
d'imaginer que des milliers d'entre vous
réfléchissent amon énigmes préférées
pour rappel voici les noms c'est un
homme a deux enfants
l'un d'eux est un garçon quelle est la
probabilité que l'autre soit un garçon
aussi et si j'adore cette énigme c'est
parce que cette énigme et ses nombreuses
variantes auront excité mes neurones
depuis des années c'est quand même fou
on a un énoncé ultra simple qui fait
trois lignes et celui ci moore a fait
réfléchir pendant plusieurs années
surtout les trois dernières années plus
fou encore ses réflexions n'ont cessé
d'évoluer et surtout de progresser
c'est très étrange parce que ce que le
mois d'il ya six ans pensait était loin
d'être idiot mais le mois d'il ya trois
ans avait une compréhension beaucoup
plus fine du problème et pourtant le
mois de jour d'hui trouve que la
réflexion du mois d'il ya trois ans
étaient très approximatifs encore plus
fou encore cette énigme des deux enfants
est en fait intimement liée aux
problèmes de trouver les fondements du
savoir et en particulier au bail et
diane isme cette étrange épistémologie
dont ils viennent mentale monsieur fille
et alexandre techno prog vous ont parlé
sur leurs chaînes respectives en
français et dont jules haag aleph et
crache lorsqu'on parlait sur la chaîne
en anglais et à laquelle j'ai dédié mon
premier bouquin qui d'ailleurs un sacré
pavé
je lis sacré pavé hashtag acheter le
livre
et pour ceux qui ont peur que cette
série de vidéos qu'on commence sera
retombantes avec le contenu du livre
rassurez-vous la plupart des vidéos de
la série porteront sur des sujets qui
n'apparaissent pas dans le livre et plus
généralement je vais essayer d'être
avant tout complémentaire du livre
bref même si vous avez très bien lu le
livre vous devriez beaucoup apprendre
avec cette série de vidéos et si vous
suivait très attentivement cette série
vous apprendrez quand même énormément en
lisant le livre hashtag acheter le livre
revenons-en au bail à nice mme le
béziers nice mme c'est une philosophie
du savoir qui en tout cas dans sa
version sur le mono fils tu prétends
être universel autrement dit pour une
pure bayésienne penser juste c'est ni
plus ni moins appliquer les préceptes du
bail à nice mme et ses préceptes sont
étonnamment simple il s'agit de faire du
langage des probabilités
le langage du savoir ou dit autrement
pour la pure bayésienne
raisonnement est juste si et seulement
si il est conforme aux lois des
probabilités en particulier comme on en
parlera longuement le belge yanis mans
vient du coup à conclure que de très
nombreux principes que l'on associe
souvent à la méthode scientifique à la
rationalité et à l'esprit de critiques
sont en fait des sophismes ou du moins
beaucoup de ces principes violent les
lois des probabilités
or ces principes sont si souvent
acceptées communiqué est célébrée par
tant de gens très intelligents à
commencer par des scientifiques
bon bien sûr ça ne veut absolument pas
dire que mon intuition est plus
intelligente que ces scientifiques ou
que les conclusions de vos intuitions
sont aussi crédibles que le consensus
scientifique bien au contraire il ya
énormément d'arguments bayésiens pour
affirmer que le consensus scientifique
sera presque toujours largement plus
fiable que votre intuition
non ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que
selon le bail à nice mme les lois des
probabilités et leurs conséquences sont
beaucoup plus fiables que les avis des
experts et que du coup si un calcul
vraiment bayésiens contredit les avis
des experts
alors je ferai beaucoup plus confiance
aux calculs vraiment bayésiens qu'aux
experts comme ce fut le cas par exemple
pour salies clark ou pour le mont tyrol
n'y viendra alors malheureusement les
lois des probabilités sont extrêmement
difficiles à appliquer en pratique comme
l'illustrent si merveilleusement
l'énigme des deux enfants d'ailleurs
comme je lé avoué il ya quelques
semaines il se trouve que même au moment
de la publication de mon pavé
la solution à l'énigme des deux enfants
que j'avais en tête n'était toujours pas
conforme aux lois des probabilités
ce qui explique pourquoi j'étais un peu
à côté de la plaque en particulier et je
n'ai aucun problème à admettre que le
mois d'aujourd'hui est malheureusement
très loin de comprendre et de pouvoir
appliquer les lois des probabilités
je suis très très très loin des
standards de la pure bayésienne et du
coup il est extrêmement prétentieux et
rené pour moi d'affirmer que je suis
bayésiens je m'excuse pour toutes les
fois où ça m'a échappé
je ne suis pas parisien la quasi
totalité de mes réflexions et de mes
déclarations violent les fondements du
belgian isme et oui c'est triste
néanmoins j'aspire à tendre vers le
belize à nice mme en ce sens je suis un
aspirant bayésiens et en tant que tel je
suis absolument ravi de découvrir et de
comprendre les cas où mon crétin de
cerveau divergent significativement du
calcul
désir et c'est pour ça que je kiffe
l'énigme des deux enfants mois après
mois et pendant des années cette énigme
redoutable n'a cessé de souligner
l'incompatibilité entre mes
raisonnements et les lois des
probabilités
et même si aujourd'hui je pense enfin
avoir une solution vraiment bayésienne
aller uniquement des deux enfants il est
important de voir qu'il ne s'agit là que
d'un cas d'application incroyablement
simple des lois des probabilités
en pratique je suis constamment exposés
à des informations beaucoup plus
complexe et j'ai un mal fou à utiliser
les lois des probabilités pour déduire
les implications de ces informations sur
ce que je devrais penser surtout bien
sûr sur des sujets hooligans en moi
prend le dessus
bref tout ça pour dire que cette énigme
des deux enfants c'est vraiment mon
énigmes préféré c'est vraiment une
formidable porte d'entrée vers l'univers
abracadabrantesque dubase à nice mme
mais pour traverser ses portes il est
indispensable de prendre le temps de la
réflexion et de vraiment disséquer le
problème c'est vraiment ce que je vous
invite à faire tourner le dans tous les
sens et chercher à vraiment entièrement
le cerner d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on ne
va pas résoudre ce problème
d'une part parce que pour bien le
résoudre il me faudrait d'abord
introduire la formule de belize cette
équation fantastique des lois des
probabilités que j'ai pompeusement
appelée la formule du savoir dans mon
livre mais d'autre part et surtout
j'aimerais vous amener à réfléchir à ce
problème davantage encore
j'aimerais que vous me dis qu'est ce
problème quand vous avez un moment de
temps libre sous la douche ou en vous
baladant j'aimerais que cette énigme
vous accompagne pendant les mois à venir
pour cela plutôt que de vous donner la
bonne solution
je vais essayer de vous montrer à quel
point ce problème et piégeux en vous
proposant deux solutions différentes et
incompatibles au problème et oui même si
ces deux solutions vont paraître très
convaincante
l'une d'elles sera en fait
insatisfaisante vous êtes prêts c'est
parti fait non avant de parler des deux
solutions
je vais clarifier certains points
techniques et simplifier autant que
possible le problème
la première remarque et qu'un nouveau né
est en fait plus probablement un garçon
qu'une fille à 51 contre 49 % et par
ailleurs la survie du nouveau né peut
dépendre de son sexe notamment en
fonction des lieux et des époques et oui
il ya pas si longtemps la mortalité
infantile était loin d'être négligeable
et tout cela a fait que la probabilité
qu'un enfant soit un garçon plutôt
qu'une fille mais bon en bons
mathématiciens je vous propose de
négliger ces détails
certes ces détails sont techniques
important pour résoudre exactement
l'énigme mais en fait ce qui est
fascinant ce n'est pas la réponse à
l'énigme en tout cas ce qui me fascine
ce sont des subtilités de la méthode de
résolution de l'énigme et de ses
variantes
et puis de toute façon la prise en
compte de ces effets ne modifierait pas
drastiquement la réponse à l'énigme donc
idem on va ignorer le fait que le sexe
de deux enfants notamment pour deux
enfants successifs ne sont en fait pas
indépendant selon cette étude en tout
cas un garçon a légèrement plus de
chances d'avoir un frère et une soeur
et puis il ya aussi le cas des jumeaux
voir des individus non binaire bon qu'on
rentre un peu dans les détails c'est un
petit peu compliqué donc je vous propose
de faire simple on va donc supposer
qu'un enfant a une probabilité un sur
deux d'être un garçon quel que soit le
sexe de son frangin ainsi l'aîné est un
garçon avec projet était un demi et
indépendamment du sexe de l'aîné le
cadet est un garçon avec probabilité 1/2
aussi du coup on a garé son garçon avait
profité un quart garçon fille avait
profité un quart fille garçon est
probabilité un quart et fifi ait
probabilité un quart ou du moins c'est
ce que l'on peut croire avant de savoir
que l'un des enfants est un garçon oui
parce que maintenant que l'on sait que
l'un des enfants est un garçon on sait
que le cas fifi est faux il nous reste
alors trois possibilités garçon garçon
garçon fille et fille garçon
or une seule de ces trois possibilités
est un cas où l'un des enfants est un
garçon et l'autre est un garçon aussi à
savoir lequel garçon garçon ne s'agit
que d'un cas parmi 3 on conclut donc que
la probabilité que l'autre enfant soit
un garçon aussi est égale à un tiers
ça vous paraît clair on a priori quatre
possibilités et qu probable les
hypothèses exclu l'une d'elles est parmi
les trois quarts restants une seule
correspond au fait que l'autre enfant
est un garçon aussi ok ça c'était la
première solution dont je parle
d'ailleurs dans mon livre mais est-elle
juste est ce une bonne solution
ou plutôt est ce une solution qui donne
la bonne réponse et bien je vous propose
une réponse alternative pour défier vos
intuitions dans notre première solution
on a ordonné les enfants par âge on a
considéré l'aîné et le cadet mais
ordonnée les enfants parages c'est assez
arbitraire
pourquoi ne pas plutôt les ordonner par
ordre lexicographique de leur prénom
mieux encore pourquoi ne pas les ordres
donnés par l'ordre dans lequel on
on en parlait oui parce que le premier
enfant dont on entend parler a autant de
chances d'être un garçon qu'une fille et
quel que soit le sexe de ce premier
enfant
le second enfant dont on entend parler a
également autant de chances d'être un
garçon d'une fille mais alors si je
reprends mon énoncés je me rends compte
que tout ce que j'apprends c'est que le
premier enfant dont j'entends parler est
un garçon mais on a vu que quel que soit
le sexe de cet enfant l'autre a autant
de chances d'être un garçon qu'une fille
il se trouve que le premier enfant dont
on entend parler est un garçon mais ça
ne change rien à la probabilité que le
second enfant soit un garçon
cette probabilité demeure 1/2 incroyable
où vient de présenter une deuxième
solution qui semble elle aussi justes
mais qui fournit un résultat différent
de la première solution il ya quelque
chose de très bizarre qui se passe et
c'est pour ça que j'adore cette énigme
des deux enfants elle est terriblement
plus subtil et plus piégeuse qu'elle ne
le paraît et bien votre tâche dans le
mois à venir ça va être de clarifier
tous à deux vous même et de rejeter
l'une des solutions et pour cela je vous
encourage vivement à poser le problème à
vos amis à les faire réfléchir alors
présenté les deux solutions
contradictoires et à débattre ensemble
si possible bien débattre de comment
clarifier au mieux ce paradoxe des deux
enfants et puis n'hésitez pas à
concocter et si possible résoudre toutes
sortes de variantes de ce fabuleux
problème comme au hasard supposer que
l'un des enfants est un garçon né un
lundi entre 18h et 19h ou si l'un des
enfants est appelé julien ou si l'un des
enfants est un garçon qui brille à
l'école
ce problème est vraiment un problème
fabuleux et je n'ai pas envie de ce pôle
et vos réflexions dès à présent elle
espère que j'avais mais ce premier
épisode de cette super série qui
s'annonce je suis vraiment très excité
par rapport à tout ça je peux dire que
le prochain script sont déjà rejoué
écrit et ça bouillonne dans la tête et
j'étais excité par rapport à tout ça ça
va être vraiment génial il ya plein de
trucs assez assez floue à dire de vous
invitant à beaucoup réfléchir à ce
problème tout seul si possible avec vos
amis peut pas avoir d'un disque qui
vient
quelque part d'ikea pendant au début on
résoudra ce problème plus tard dans
cette série ça va prendre plusieurs
épisodes quand on se retourne deux pays
et puis d'autres exemples pour essayer
de nous amener à raisonner de façon
bayésienne c'est vraiment pas facile
mais on va voir on va essayer d'y
arriver
si jamais vous perdez passant si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur ce paradoxe
des deux enfants il ya une très bonne
page wikipédia sur ce paradoxe avec
beaucoup d'autres réflexions qui
pourront nourrir un peu vos débats mais
encore une fois je pense que tout ce
qu'il y ait encore la réponse ce que je
trouve satisfaisante en tout cas
d'imprévu bayésiens si vous avez aimé
cet épisode dont celle de l'ikea le
commentaire le partage et pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci aux types de repos leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois nous savons maintenant
que cette fille mais un mardi quelle est
donc la probabilité que ce couple est
alors de finition patel changer ou non
donc la probabilité qu'il ira garçons et
de deux tiers tout simplement
alors voilà j'espère que le schéma
précédent était clair et que vous voyez
bien pourquoi la réponse et deux tiers
sauf qu'en fait c'est faux alors c'est
pas faux faux il n'ya pas d'entourloupe
dans ce que je vous ai raconté